all right let's and gentlemen it's
Monday after it's not Monday [ __ ] I
meant it's a start with a little
excitement I Saarland down good god man
it is not him forever that's why I
thought squad cars
squad what your entire what time is it I
woke up at 5:00 a.m.
me too man I've been shooting my own
brother 5:00 a.m. they back from Dublin
zero sleep I was two hours sleep on the
roads fine yeah mate have you time it's
been a beast a [ __ ] long they gonna
B's odd it is a studio Thursday
no it's Wednesday to Wednesday you got
this think I got brain trauma you'll
figure it out um you're back
did you like England or Ireland better
um I liked it all man London was dope
Manchester was cool
I love Dublin though I love Dublin
Ireland he was so friendly yeah you were
so friendly it's weird cause like
everyone has what they call the gift of
the gab you know I'm fans and that's why
they relate to Kairos for story count
that's why they relate to Connor because
did I get like the my barber his name
was Connor there's a lot of commoners
out there but my barber others whose
brilliance named Connor same barber for
beaver that's why Family Guy anyways he
was saying he's a cow one of the reasons
like Connor so big hairs like we all
have that friend who's just like him
like yeah we relate the way he talks
like that's the way it goes here yeah
like really does the atom man everyone
so I get that barber shop they're like
three barbers there who were beast at
talking like there's a million
podcasters walked around there the Irish
we always have a tradition of
storytelling and in fact there's a book
called how the Irish saved Western
civilization or save civilization by
historian and would be what he says is
that the scribes most of that part of
the world was illiterate but the scribes
the priests and I'm sorry the priests
the clergy they learned how to write so
what they did was they on during the
Dark Ages they basically copied all the
books and carried them around with them
they kept them in libraries because it
was knowledge they didn't want to they
didn't want you know people to lose like
with the Greeks or the Romans in good
soil right and so when you would sit
around a campfire they would
health stories and you would pass legend
on through word of mouth anything they
say was cool yes
and then boy did I [ __ ] up meet her
chin Jay and I went to a pub there like
an old-school pub his well actually when
the oldest pubs in I live that shit's
where rebels fought off the English
there's bullet holes in the wall yeah
family owned since the begin since like
1840 or whatever the [ __ ] it was she was
raised upstairs then she they worked
downstairs she's the only one there
lives upstairs
so his butt holes in it was so cool so
I'm there I see a group of attractive
ladies order Guinness you know I'm not
figuring I don't know mother drink it up
against but these Guinness were purple
they were purple they're purple yeah you
were staying out on your Instagram they
were purple Guiness I thought well that
looks like in delicious I'll take three
of those now wasn't awaiting no no they
were they my Instagram it was I mean
purple problem I've seen Guinness in the
Stasia Baz a consequence was purple
Guinness those look delicious three for
me my mates and this dude my me my dad's
my mate so Hobbs come from Manchester
right so I like this grisly Irish man
the I whose family fall off the English
in this bar and it's been family home
forever
I said three purple Guinness sir because
are you sure I went yeah
alright given to me I had no idea
thank you I'm not supposed to do that
yeah we saw in other words I mean you're
a loyalist to the British flag - I wish
you something cool like that
I'm half English so I could get away
with that no it means you suck talk it
means you're a certified Irish man right
well I don't care dude he ran I did
you're not eating
other came out on my so I got quite a
chunk and that means you're an ID D it
means you you deep throat and swallow
the gravy so they have it they have a
[ __ ] color for the beer so you're
sending a signal to other guys yeah
basically board i like it's--for chicks
in space likewise it's like ordered a
piña colada i can catch it because they
take the Guinness and we play
blackcurrant man
ah let me tell you something though but
I know you got a sweet tooth so it was
to do this few teeth uh-huh that [ __ ]
was the best thing I've ever had my lips
but I got roasted so bad on line foot so
bad
articles are written out there and write
your headline articles men out there
making fun of me really and at the shows
people would boo me and you know what
I'd come out on stage with a Guinness
like no there's no it's not purple it's
up please I fall I started if you show
apologizing in fact I went right here to
start this off hey hey hey how about a
heads up though on some of the little
things in life
oh I should have known because it's just
chicks ordering it it tastes like a
black wine gum though it was so
delicious behind closed door I wish I
could have drank that [ __ ] oh man no
black currant how good was it though
delicious man it was Knightly so you
don't have again you guys gobbled down
couple of those and then gobbled some
Irish cause I was gonna say and then
then then it's only right man
of course it's only right went to that
filthy bathroom got on your knees stain
them expensive jeans all that Irish piss
and just gobble gobble gobble gobble
where we go with Nick talk like a
leprechaun so uh interesting bit weird
right yeah and then so oh my dice went
diet you know yes diet yeah all that
diet show not a lot of Holman
restaurants and paleo stuff it was good
food but like in I in London I fish and
chips every meal yeah in in double-a
tournament certified alcoholic yeah I
literally would wake up and drink
Guinness I was on stage every night
Guinness during the show so I'm feed me
agin it yeah the crowd would yell ciao
ciao
Chuck I'm chugging dinner well so what
would you drink in them alcoholic what
would you drink before when water would
make you sick you had to drink you know
spirits because that that's what kept
you from getting dysentery and cholera
and all kinds of [ __ ] they drink black
beer buddy and they say but it's which
is the Irish were like that's healthy
for your members vitamins I'm like yeah
I know I get that I get that it's sick
like a cold like a syrup yeah I feel
sick yeah and I they're like oh if you
drink too much there's so much fiber
gonna [ __ ] your pants fiber there's so
much fiber and I guess on it [ __ ] my
pastors Yuchun know bring it on i Lenexa
getting a lot of beer tastes different
than American Guinness but it was so
delicious
I'm addicted dude yeah my mouth is
salivating right now it was so good bro
he would loved it I've been a [ __ ]
leave in the Limerick
dude every time a limerick Irish burger
like that that [ __ ] everyone was so nice
yeah like so cool
I bet and then I guy was eatin fish and
chips and London and Manchester every
meal literally every meal on fish and
chips and then I wouldn't drink too much
in London then in Dublin Guinness I'd
have an Irish Breakfast which is just
listen Ireland it's just magic too much
no no no no it's it's [ __ ] we had
what would it was eggs it was eggs over
hard basically or over medium sausage
sausage beans bacon bacon blood sausage
oh boy uh mushrooms tomatoes and nobody
know beans sometimes there's beans on
one of them at they had so you know the
only beans were in that's your time out
of traditional English preservation
irish breakfast you got blood sausage
disgusting you got good often so look
like hey hey let me take his up now I
hate chin you're Korean I'm right here
Oh a chin - in Korean we we'd be an
arrest I'm like you can get every
pickled hard boil eggs early I don't
know bro
I sure [ __ ] don't know how I would never
know and then he always wants you to
like convenience stores I get Tesco's
you want the sushi from like the Kmart
oh boy he's one of those guys do you if
you will Chris yeah and I feel grateful
hey girl quiet Gayle quiet and sneak off
somewhere you don't know what it's doing
just disappear come back with a
distended belly did this sound like
[ __ ] go around eating olive oils eggs
and pork rinds yep sushi it's packaged
in something that oh I can't believe I
crab me dude taught and then I would I
would buy a shitload of wine guns and
candy everywhere and just lime gums who
the [ __ ] is the wine come oh my god it's
like a candy made out of angel skin
really so nice man yeah oh they're my
favorites I bought a shitload of those I
just [ __ ] my undies at night cuz I can't
sleep eating those man deal my jet lag
yeah jet lag I never I'm saying people
say you get over it [ __ ] I never
ever made up
at 3:00 in the morning wake up but you
know the leaven yeah I know rhythm have
to do short too like oh god is like
waffles I'm gay
awesome but it's full-time duty oh no
tell us there were nice hotels are real
nice yeah and then but you know I like
Rogen's fanbase bring some weed yeah
I'm brings me candy cash so much candy
now what about the Hoff I didn't find
yourself some good coffee spots not a
lot of Starbucks that's it Starbucks
there's a costa's which was nice I found
that we found all that one place the
only reason it caught my because it said
something about the oh the flat white
Rises we have yeah man what you know
making fun of darkness cut my because we
we are in our house a revolver coffee
something like that from Vancouver now I
found a couple hipster spots you have
nothing nothing like here yeah the tea
really good tea the food was actually
really good shopping was good some good
shopping right shopping yeah really good
shot cuz that dollar goes a long way
no just orders it up like they bought
this coat you would love this coat John
Varvatos out there yeah
but day oh it's only you can only get in
London's this goat suede go this way
edge of coat you should be yeah yeah
sick now are you on girl oh yeah well I
would keep saying this into a giant
spiky parents not my baby's not Miami
not Miami long winters the long winters
and the rainy wet winters I mean is
there a squat rack Amy where's my help
here let me take hey hey what let me
hate anyone her cheek imma give you let
me give you a Brit let me let me give
you the breakdown flat ass set two spots
egg baked it's flat ass pale skin they'd
look like extras from [ __ ] you go to
Scotland it's not gonna get much better
Scotland Ireland yeah I I go squat I do
Ireland a million years ago I judge the
Miss Ireland Miss Ireland competition
right so what is it yes I was a beauty
competition and and I'm not gonna lie to
you now not gonna lie to you might have
gotten I think was the third runner-up
or something like that I can't remember
but we got a little busy in a bathroom
sure did that was all good good stuff
dirty she was sitting on the toilet deal
here's the thing
but I was I know what you mean because I
was looking at the cream of the crop and
those long winners those wet long
winners with all that beer and all that
bread and all that stuff and it is not a
lot of it attend unless you're on the
farm pushing a grain mill there's no
really like boom boom because out it's
just not it 8 Brazil Columbia or Miami
or Mexico or microstrain let's be able
to all right you know I'm saying and
they know that and they agree with that
they agree with yeah I'm telling you oh
man I was used to in used to tell me
like dude I get out and see the world my
daddy so yeah yeah see the world and
finally comedies brought me around the
world and I got to be honest that I
loved London I loved Manchester that bit
was phenomenal the doublet on Tony life
change I want to go to Delos life I need
that for me I was so clear talking about
it you're out of town with so much
history well I mean the Irish have been
through the [ __ ] first off they Bend
with it with the famine I mean they've
been through the [ __ ] when they came to
this country for the most part one I
believe is a one-in-eight Irishman came
to Ellis Island
the famine in the 1890s was so bad bro
we went to uh I don't mean to rugby we
went to uh I did some sightseeing to be
proud of me I saw some history go ahead
to London Bridge oh they had tar the
London Tower sorry that's all the bridge
- and Big Ben not that big
no not that big I think you ever been
you've been England before I've never
been but I've never been to London but
your mother but I've never been outside
of America my kid I know that sir yeah I
don't go anywhere
oh my there's lots to like when you were
telling me that that is the first time
you've been in Europe to do comedy Wow I
went to okay we got a stop I went to the
Louvre at Tower of London yeah I was on
Ireland now dad did the crown jewels
there yeah let me take some other crown
jewels the line was simply too long so I
concealed it I want all those cool
jewels moving on fella exactly what I
would do I don't give a photo I went
first and I'll just Google who I went
where we're the torture chamber happened
I felt like I was in Game of Thrones
yeah now was that in the Tower of London
yeah because you know spent some time up
there very famous people I got a wild I
believe is out there it's all over the
walls cool for being a homosexual yep
being a subversive
yeah
a lot of it like that really cool Wow so
that that's about other sightseeing it
is well exciting I'm not a big sexy guy
well for me it's like you I don't I like
that stuff but during the day I don't
know I was in Montreal and I was at
which is a very French city so Montreal
was really hopefully speaking French
I've been by state accommodation of the
English culture and French culture but
very very friends and the East I believe
these part of Montreal is very French
right there they wanted us to see they
want to give us they want to get
everything's in front and I hadn't
written even Starbucks a cafe Starbucks
yes right and but the thing about being
a tourist and sightseeing my family my
beautiful wife and you know she likes to
do things with the kids god bless her
and I'm glad she does it but we got into
one in double decker buses because my
son always my rival yeah that's about
you kind of don't do it where the Sun
shines down now you know I don't do well
somehow Imperials don't know
and yeah I'm you drive and you see like
oh in that building so to live in that
building you I'd rather I'm not kidding
I would rather be in a Dennis Jia Jia
board I'd rather have you drill my teeth
no novocaine CJ and [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
James chill yes we went into the
Guinness Factory I'm like nom B that's
the third biggest Church in North
America I don't care meaning I want good
food I want to have a laugh and I want
to I want to shake it up know that I
can't do it yeah yes good like again
that pub man was the coolest [ __ ] bar
but that's what I like to do I like to
go to a pub I like to see the history I
had to feel the warmth I some
conversations with got you know real
like straight-up Dublin okay you get
another that's how you actually get to
know a city it was growing people that
lived there it was great man it was so
cool and then I hired these guys who I
don't you remember you can tell me which
ones so the guy doing the mini docked
throw up and Luke Phillip and Luke and
then we had our boy the photographer he
Lee who was brilliant I got to people
you call him up yeah and so I hired this
team and they put doing like a little
sizzle real friends again I put out
but then they they're putting me like a
mini Docs almost like embedded map last
series
and the dish they're shown the whole
trip and it can be sick as you know
whatever six shows different outfit
every show so since rosters table what's
up table will so don't pooh-pooh boom so
I'm with those guys right who like me
born and raised there so they'd say go
eat here or do this go to this pub and
then he goes yo man what you would do
it's our last I just she's oh that pub
right over there and that was the real
historical you know this is like a
proper in iron and you had cameras on
you the whole time when you're doing
this uh yeah yeah enough but it would be
worth it well if you take a great record
for your life I mean what an amazing
faster sell out of that this club of all
does amazing yeah nuts now um note with
this this is what was flattering being
you appreciate this cuz I mean most of
us because our your help he goes uh man
you got a ditch the big brown thing he's
a big brown breakdown thing I went like
us you did an hour-plus of comedy up
there you know so people come to us go
man we love the want to come the show
but he's just doing this podcast we're
gonna fight and then they go holy [ __ ]
he's like an hour they didn't call honey
shop yeah it's a sprint table I was
going to tell you that yeah yeah okay
well that's what I do now likes just
sign because even because you can take
your time with that you did you think
but I do I think that if you're doing
because I thought of that when I saw you
in New York where you're doing that much
stand-up and I went you know pretty soon
you just say Brennan shop that's what
we're doing and moving forward yeah
because the guys like yeah
to certain fan questions people I go
what do you think of this fighter we
think of that fight now you know I'm
what given depth breakdown my to give my
opinion but it's really just stand up
yeah yeah yeah it was cool cuz I was
finding stuff on stage with current
events on more easier the more you do
that schools in it's just getting your
reps in and finding things out but the
so you felt that what was the difference
between the European experience
sensibility and being in LA uh they were
so I think they were super pass it like
really what would you say to you've been
on all the shows with me big round
breakdown
having to go the past like the passion
and Dublin in London was just it's hard
to describe man I can Dublin I don't
know like I'd be tired but as soon as I
hit that crowd the energy from them
you're talking about 2:00 in the
afternoon
on a Monday that picture so while you're
getting people [ __ ] yeah that's very
afternoon and not like I entered ah not
unbelievable nuts yeah I saw that some
do that get kicked out two in the
afternoon and be like what are were they
already drinking yeah yeah oh yeah
amazed Dublin like the first night like
the crowds you know having fun they're
not obnoxious but I'm fun the first
night I will time you open doors that
he'll stab Mayo on mine it eats at 8:30
I don't have an opener so they're gonna
be sitting there drinking for now now I
can't have that
well for me I can't because it shows
basic dignity hours and hours out
expanding there and yeah I can't I said
I came hat like you can tell the
difference in energy all that make sense
yeah so should you open the doors hour
before not going it's not going sooner
yeah a lot one just sitting that's max
man now did because that's when also
people drink a little too much but yeah
yeah imagine you have rabble rouser say
that's exactly I don't like Brian would
never like we never would never do this
yeah you just can't today I don't want
them saying that long though you should
get him soon what a [ __ ] experience
it's great bro so cool J sob loved it
did some cool stuff I she filmed with
Mac life found out rue now James bitter
five I'm Pierre a did Jake go out late
night when you were hitting this chili
challenge I did I went to a club yeah no
Jay doesn't Jay Jake and it'll be four
in the morning and Jay still got my
balance and she's like I'm down a Jay
you gotta wake up early
give me sleep know you that [ __ ] I go
up for hours shark now sharks don't
sleep that guy doesn't need sleep yeah
for do it sleep moving him do it seen
him do it I like dead he goes well
because I think Jim sleeping in he looks
at Maggie playing us if you can do the
tour lives
you better gonna hang out late wake up
early dead serious on it I guess man I
guess yeah by the way
fuel himself up with about six knickers
bars and tell you to [ __ ] off when he
told me he'd better and then a but also
out do you also won't shut the [ __ ] up
the entire time you're with them he's
like that kid from Jerry Maguire yeah
just dropping fast all time I was we
talking about though every directing job
he saw many super easy doable you know
what the thing about those is and starts
going over the at the ratio the axles I
literally for days I like to it you guys
should
I don't care about that old-school
mini-cooper
I do not kick give me give my brain he's
laughs why I walk in FY I walk in Google
and it's like all of us have facts and
something there really and then you look
at it I made a mistake
Jay's not making a mistake yeah the
computer [ __ ] whiz he's I mean we got
it down to a [ __ ] it's good to go
thrifting because you had Jay run VIP
and security in that jindal producing
and it was we just got it down to a
[ __ ] science beautiful any fun yeah
Jen would not shut the [ __ ] up though
he's a ton of everything it's fine I
love it literally literally human
cyclopædia unbelievable
everything and then you know we you know
cuz I bought that in Porsche and Jay has
a Porsche and then we were talking about
when the first night we got their chin
wasn't there yet he talked about
Porsches for I timed it over two hours
but histories of Porsche is not like
yeah yeah he likes cleaning his Porsche
too he actually really likes cleaning is
he likes Porsches he likes cars he likes
nice clothes
and he loves sports correct was he [ __ ]
interesting get her argument with him on
that you better know your stuff and he's
very becoming very defensive of me so it
was critical he will come at you like
splatter his little brother super spider
monkeys little brother luck with that
yeah you have little [ __ ] French toy
soldier yes and we had a code word for
it because there's there's some guys in
that disguise you love this disguise
these Irish guys they get in the back
VIP they don't have tax like come on
let's say I'll let them in lemon because
they're sitting there they're cool dudes
yeah and they're drunk
I pretty drunk and they don't bro bigger
dudes too little bro the Irish were not
small now and they go on people no not
on and he goes wrong if this isn't the
best story I've ever heard
song way I'll let you punch me in the
face debt in the spring goes dead
serious and they're weird accents you
know yeah I do like DAGs anyways so I go
I owe to the story I tell story on how
last time because you see there Connor
beat Brando or whatever and Cody dollar
and fought on that card and there an
elevator with Cody and there's it's all
it's a thirty minute story and halfway
through the story I give you've already
performed my second show it's 1:00 a.m.
that's that one's a long [ __ ] Tecate
meet
tough it's one a tough tough so I'm them
my guy and he goes it's gonna be the
best show you've ever heard I went
brother I love pretty fascinating life
this story better be [ __ ] good it's
the best I've ever heard
I said before I even start are the girls
involved he is no I went then you're
already out you're already out here's no
no no Mia so he tells story long story
short there an elevator a scuffle
happened
Cody vouch firm so they didn't get
arrested there's no one ever got hit
there's no strikes nothing that's clear
and then they were upstairs and went to
party I like where the chicks in that
party goes no I went that's your story
oh yeah get the [ __ ] up and he started
laughing get the [ __ ] down citizen and
then do you know start laughing and then
they got a little too comfortable and
there those have Guinness for me like
drinks yeah so I started drinking my
[ __ ] and the security guard in jail like
dude you can't have that man and he's
like no no shops that I can't bend
inside can have it and then it got a
little weird so our code word code word
was is there any more wine gum and then
the old shark eyes doll smell put it
into beast mode yeah
the old shark dies when went deck out a
shovers I hope you all got it yo yo yo
shovers out an old shark eyes went
Dexter on them because I went uh huh
fellas you got a more wine gun to jiggle
and then just start doing work got these
two crabs do let me Shepherd you boys on
out of here let me just kind of get my
big old body in the way you don't really
get manhandled I get manhandled you
don't get guys grabbing you and putting
their arms around you much no I'll tell
you what was weird with the with the
London and Irish crowds is like in
America the black cat you know I'll take
a picture with the guy that'd be there
with their wife or girl who's a dime
piece I always say damn
yeah I'm assuming you forced her to go
in like yes you know the board and the
in America go yeah I get a picture with
him London Island like ain't no picture
one girls like can i light in there girl
get a picture oh it's very interesting
battle mirror at all but there's mm-hmm
yeah like just like one girl was that
smoke show and I got yeah and she takes
picture of a man she goes I didn't only
were I had really fun I'm like that man
that makes me feel the best when people
you know don't know me still laugh like
that's why I do it well wha and then I
don't want a picture and he just I mean
rough Dugas no she does
I went oh alright yeah yeah I am I'm not
gonna [ __ ] roll Riggs and Jesus good
I didn't mark your armor on no there was
something that
yeah like marry couples everything like
nah she's good like well interesting she
talked was this like 1950s she's a
housewife she can't live as well
remember what when was a first of all
abortion just became legal divorce no
abortion still not we still illegal to
have an abortion joke that killed their
because of oh okay this is now in that
that of course enjoy divorce wasn't
legal for the longest time can you see
when divorce was allowed in Ireland in
in Dublin because it was okay water and
storm on top of the world right before I
realize women around here have it really
hey well hey how about in Russia
yeah [ __ ] yeah they do comparatively oh
- a lot of gory accruing some but
Julian's Japan these are very so
chauvinistic society Africa yeah they've
no name a little country women here at
it Rehana not gonna cry yep Canada ha
has not yet I don't matter the more I
watch Game of Thrones you know what I'm
gonna start puffing my chest a little
more laying the law down you know that's
right we're goddamn reason
[ __ ] right yeah just Cox why cuz it
said so that's why
why cuz it's the way God intended right
now sirens so I try Fox I've at Mariel's
you see what happens when you get with
your girl see what happens
I'm telling man I want you to us Game of
Thrones that she can do [ __ ] you can
wear I'm frying pan in your [ __ ] in
your she'll be one rock wall yeah in the
basement shove a gun Wow hey I had a
basement first of all second mom turn on
right now is a Paul Kaplan in the garage
a plug and she were in a ball gag in the
payoff gotta block around the mouth hey
bro that's kinda illegal on us you
happen on Game of Thrones out of my
[ __ ] this is Game of Thrones you step
into my [ __ ] doorway wearing wearing
wearing [ __ ] Dark Ages England right
now wow that's how I like to bro all gag
ball cash nowhere ball gag dude the
crowd would ask everybody I'm like
you're talking about the certified dick
diver and kill
we are do a certified dick diver shirt
yeah it's having a good idea but don't
put Nick divers foot sdd and have like
the scuba like the original say and how
it was small but but you could have like
the eggplant I don't think guys are
gonna wear certified okay well it's
hilarious yeah yeah or you could have
you got why dig die you certified you
see DD c DD why apostle I feel like c DD
certified they have like the diver but
in his goggles is the eggplant emoji
like for you he's diving or you have
coral will you dive in coral it it's all
dick yeah it's just a quick you got a
nice guys it looks like coral but then
there's a clownfish in the middle just
sucking on them alright maybe got to go
there huh well that's just keeping it
coral the coral for DX well no one's
wearing a shirt with coral dicks yeah
but you gotta you got intervals Rider
you got to describe it I mean you got it
disguised as little c upon close on to
talk about this just like big scuba like
snorkeling goggles yeah snorkel and then
the mirror off the the the reflection
off the thing is that is a eggplant
emoji I thought back then a guy B is
behind him sodomizing him underwater
knows where mustard bread no one right
answer you can't have that I don't know
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying we
cannot have that I'll tell you what was
a hit in Dublin what's that and I kind
of thought it was going to be I wear
that shirt said 49 and one that barstool
sports sent me
you know kids for Maryland's 49 oh my
all think oh nice I bet it a certified
dick that he wins and I think the hit it
is in which is asking bar so I didn't
make that shirt Marshall sent to me
pretty I just save it for that um I
think you addressed this a little bit
and I heard it from a very reliable
source and saw it with my own eyes as in
attacks from a very reliable source ah
I'm nervous we gonna figure though I was
gonna ask you
I've heard they did should wait can I
whisper it to you to see if I can say it
out loud uh you're chewing to just edit
this yeah we don't whisper it to me I'm
never edit oh I'll just bring it out
yeah you can bring it up cuz wait you
think ah but who's your source
now let's lie your source it is yes and
then well that's not a good I know came
from who yeah he was there but he did
text you that to me anyway well now now
you gotta get it out yeah yeah well now
the people he might [ __ ] yeah so so um I
heard from a very reliable source that
uh dr. Polly I want to hear it keep
doing here late I heard that Conor
McGregor gave Paulie Malignaggi legit
world champion fits for 12 rounds and I
wanna say an ass-whooping cuz I don't
wanna be disrespectful but fits gave him
some problems big problems what is your
take on that and that was from somebody
was there and you know it is yeah um so
I've looked into Polly I've soldier
people that was there I also listening I
love Connor I love Paula like better I
stay in the middle guy right that middle
dick Lane
you know the reports of did Polly get
his ass whipped is that's not true it's
not true
I know there was there some tough rounds
I know that there's some tough rounds
and if the rounds went on from what I
heard you know Polly was doing some
stuff they both landed really good shots
castor can i internet jack one thing
let's let's have a caveat I don't think
Paul Paul II has boxed for many years
and probably wasn't in boxing shape
everything about shape to go 12 rounds
right and all that he has in boxing how
long yeah yeah I mean months you know a
while he retired I got all yours yeah
but you have the back in the gym yes
that's fair to say but still world
champion um you know the the fact that
the reports that counter beat his ass I
don't know if that's true kind of bigger
than him not beer yeah taller you know
quick is in shape but the same thing you
know that that stuff with the whole
Polly stuff and I said this to Polly the
thing was Pauline Connor is Polly he's
like us he's like is expensive guy and
Polly girls got cocked all that [ __ ] you
know six months ago and you know I
thought we'd spar and be all good just
like you know the way we define us do
like Sharon you mix it out and I'm here
yeah his thing is and I told polish ago
but dude when he brought you in you know
if you go back to us in the reports
especially on show time to go ye bring
paulina goes to [ __ ] him up dead space
and he was in like ha just joking
Connor just [ __ ] him up jeez because six
months ago or seven months ago and
probably cuz I could be in one hand time
my back man one of the reason what makes
Connor such an elite winner and yeah
elite athlete I said personal yep if you
know them so they go white bring paulien
it wasn't two figures flowing out what
it was to [ __ ] him up Wow so you know I
think they thought two different they
had two different agendas hmm and from
apart from bringing me in and from Katja
you bring me in but I'm just here to
hell with you it's all good yeah you
know and so you know here Connor stream
partner goes you know Paulie you know
laugh because it worked for Showtime
came back and you know you talk [ __ ]
saying Conan had power stuff like that
so he's just havin fuel to fire I don't
know what I expected yeah and then even
after that picture got posted and from
my sources mmm
super close to Connor my source is sure
Connors team didn't leak that a second
source Lee oh I he they believe that
Connor didn't see me they'll post
pictures of spar and stuff like that
they didn't leak that one son else did
and then he got picked up in Congress
tumors like that [ __ ] it it's out there
would he gonna sure but Paulie Saul
contact unlock them didn't say anything
and then I guess when they're headed
back got dropped off the hotel and it
just bounced so then people go up all
even get paid and stop I'll probably
talk to probably mayhem on my shows be
groundbreaking something like that we'd
be fun to have him on here and just
having talked about it um you know he
left and the sergeant might get paid
helping Paulie kids probably financially
fine but remember too if you had a job
and you're supposed to work six weeks
and you work two days yeah you know I
can get paid sure so Connor never fired
me left again I'm in the middle on this
yeah I love Paula at left Connor they
they're both just so different
they both had different agendas bit of a
[ __ ] show it's not fake it's not
scripted well I don't think what Dana
and of the UFC is saying how paulie's
got picked up part's true
I know Connor did well I know that for a
fact I'm I did well and it's because
he's a really good boxer
you could also say that at least here's
what I'll say we all talk about how good
Nate Diaz is a boxer for the USC Nate
trains as a boxer he trained it on three
words camp for a long time Trey's a lot
of camps and he gets in there with real
boxers and bangs it out and been doing
it for years I think from my from where
I was sitting it looks like Conor
McGregor's actually a better boxer than
the ideas different this the prom is
like different or better different way
different can't because what Conor does
the only reason why I kind of had the
chance is fight because he's so
untraditional or he's never seen it this
is going to take Floyd a while to
download his movement and in the way he
hits something weird mall and stuff like
that and the ideas they've seen that
style since they were little they'd use
this traditional box are very good at it
yes brilliant at it but any box is
seeing up didn't eat him alive
okay I'll high level same way when
people go dancing Joshua steep a steep
is a traditional box Anthony Joshua :
you know going through that but he's
seen that style whenever language knows
what language you don't see that
notorious movement that Conor McGregor
awkward movements wins in South ball
traditional even more on Paul and Paul
he switched holding he will I know for a
fact so Polly's coming all this stuff
I'm like Nana's terrible bro wheel and
some good shots you think you're missing
a point I'm like not just but like was
it like you know unless I'm trying it
you know cuz you I don't know if he
landed some good shots and I need to
know you know I'm Bob Ryder dying on
this comment so did you get from Pauly D
I says he's top he does because one
stuff top you know but that's it that's
why you did again the place might pop
you know paulie's not you know tell
probably doesn't need more fame play
turning that stuff flies just like man
this is what it is you know I think
Polly's feelings are hurt I think
Connors here you know the show moves on
sure and you know it's good insight for
Pauly to have on the Showtime broadcast
stuff like damn sure is a fun journey
but you know I think he got a pissed off
Connor because he said things about him
earlier and I gotta get it from the
horse's mouth I need to talk to Paulie I
don't wanna you know speak out of turn
anything like that but from my sources
I'm talking to paulie belonging this guy
people and Connors can't talking people
in Dublin it's you know
you pit you paint this picture and try
the best you can wonderful whenever all
of our lens is going to that fight
how are the ticket sales they're not
good beginning they're not good again
the upper deck aren't good because
they're so expensive the bottom tier
sold the [ __ ] that doesn't surprise me
because this is the kind of money I want
to come pay per view and and gather
around a TV oh yeah you know what I mean
that it'll rather get out and go through
it's only $24.99 and do UK and Ireland
okay yeah it's a bit then it makes more
sense yeah well I'm gonna take a lot for
sure it's and it's gonna be the best
favorite of all time yeah I would
imagine it's I mean he came and watch
mainstream media right now know what
they're doing I go on Rich Eisen
tomorrow just trying to educate him a
little bit but uh yeah on the actual I'm
just just why it says it's an
interesting sight white it is what it is
why it's not this just complete you know
joke of a fight right right yeah go to
the body Conor don't try to put hands in
his face go to the body
yeah but you again you got your source
would you know that's of course you're
gonna say that you know of course thing
I said I can't you can't that's why I
don't live up with something that close
to the yeah fight I never listen to it I
couldn't kill all the time yeah yeah
yeah yeah I need an outside source yeah
who knows what's out you went right to
the guy who fought him yeah but again
Paul - you know Paul Yaffe you know
here's neon he has you know what
happened in fighter not his fighter and
world champion and jeremy'll Sandman
but the one the footage you know who
knows if that footage ever gets out at
highly it might get out of highly doubt
it in favor of Conor I would almost
guarantee when you and I were at that
gym that Martinez comes out of latina
now who's the Argentinian fighter who is
our feed our schedule Garcia Sergio
Garcia
uh she was Lee's good yeah Shane's one
and one of the things I thought was
interesting was that I think it might
have been made Donna's cousin was
fighting yeah it does cause and it was
he sparring Shawn Porter who is yeah
and somebody was videotaping and he goes
hey hey I don't want I don't want the
other side of the guy code yeah so I
don't want you videotaping so you can
download what the [ __ ] I'm doing
it's just guy code though like it's also
it's like you know there's this kind of
hidden rules in baseball where you know
there's certain things you just you
can't
but you just don't do it there's like
locker room code kind of that much
Electrike with Chris Maynard in Oh
stuffy timeout yeah as far as like a
fighter goes like it's just like vaak
bro that to be honest some [ __ ] [ __ ]
did you lose a little respect like I
know you need like views and try to get
more popular it's just like in the
fighting world and if your management
like if Frank and those guys tell them
to do that
tell me man is you're barking up the
wrong tree yeah cuz even even fight
promote the fight worlds of Oh mr. nasty
well I would even say that's is that you
don't that's not that's not really Chris
you know what you know it's like yours I
know in this town them yeah you know
it's like do it's like a a girl who has
morals and ethics and blasting a Phung a
speck on a yeah like what are you doing
that you don't need to do that I'm buddy
got in your legit coal like what you're
good person what are you doing that's
right Lex yeah I'm like oh man yeah I
had the same exact man I saw and he
keeps doing every psyche I'll you know
you can bring me off spar with you but
you have to pay me a handsome you know
I'm out I'm just like a god Chris I
don't know yeah this stuff I know
exactly we're talking about oh let's do
some current events let's do some
current of their homes to record it just
in this just in towns of certified dick
Davo a big duffel the day he was born he
was diving on [ __ ] well you heard this
already right what Trump said just
recently is using all the wait for you
right now oh yeah I thought I heard oh
here we go
what is his career best not make any
more threats to the United States they
will be met with fire and fury like the
world has never seen
he has been very threatening beyond a
normal state only ten thousand said they
will be met with fire fury and frankly
power the likes of which the governor
took has never seen before
thank you
I saw interesting fact I said North
Korea has like whatever eight nuclear
missiles it was like in America has 127
well now they have three they might have
80 and we have actually way more than
that but the biggest thing is this like
he's funny he's so funny he's like um
he's so funny the way fire and fury and
frankly power like with an ear I'm
adding power as well but did he repeat
he goes beyond a normal statement if you
want to keep this up yeah
fire they've been very threatening they
made threats in a threatening manner
like hey dude he's just - he gets so
reduced eerie though yeah North Korea
they have capabilities of reaching LA
correct
so al the idea is I admission they could
they could hit one of us well they don't
know yet but they do have
intercontinental ballistic missiles so
that would be a missile that you can fit
with a miniature warhead okay if you can
do that and it has the kind of guiding
system and it can avoid our shoot down
technology and all that look with that
yeah and they can right now they say
they can reach Guam Guam is an American
military presence in the desert with
they're threatening right now after this
long yeah got a lot of American service
members and their families they're
bombing so Rex Tillerson went to Guam
and he was like basically hey listen the
kannur 'the koreans are basically
talking again and you know it's look
michael malice who wrote a book on north
korea said that whenever they shoot
those missiles may crash into the sea
and they don't go up there trying to see
what they're doing is they're testing it
but they know it's really a lot of
experts believe that they're those tests
are being done on purpose like they're
failing on purpose so the koreans i want
to lose face there we're shooting it
we're not listening to you oh but it's
not a threat it's going into the sea so
they're kind of sabotaging it themselves
so that's one of those people think that
they can really North Koreans know that
if they ever going to drive my house now
and take five husband taxes the North
Koreans know that if they ever suicide
but they're led by a straight up Lumet
yeah but that looks scared
it'd be the end of their entire regime I
know but he's a lunatic
so you're not dealing with the regular
man who sings like that right the North
Koreans have from from the early from
the ad should be open or terrified that
the United States don't launch a
unilateral attack so they they and then
there were threats made and I came over
the president American president
essentially that that the nuclear option
was always on the table with North Korea
and their founder the founder of North
Korea after the Korean War and never
forgot that but and doesn't remember it
doesn't Russia and try to back up North
Korea I'm sorry doesn't Russia and China
back up North Korea well Russia so China
was always North Korea's biggest
influence but they're out now but China
and Russia just essentially they were
trading partners yeah China and Russia
just voted along with the United States
in the United Nations for the sanctions
the newly imposed sanctions so that's
kind of new so they're back I'm fed up
with North Korea Russia is fed up with
North Korea everybody started with North
Korea on child was using or considering
12 bargaining I know North Korea
committed suicide but you have the back
of Russia and China then you get some
yeah China and Russia everybody behind
yeah it's a wreck so listen even said
we're actually in a better place and we
were you know the trend even the Chinese
and the Russians are like look guys the
[ __ ] you doing you know now the danger
is if they have 80 nuclear warhead hurt
it'll have that many well there that's
that's one speculation by nuclear
experts very tough to tell because
everything to do is underground yeah now
that the likes of fire and fury is kind
of a paraphrase of Harry Truman who
talked about you know remember who
dropped the bomb on Nagasaki and
Hiroshima Harry Truman the end of World
War two and I believe scary stuff it's
scary
yes it is but then hopefully the boy
Tillerson Secretary of State said I
think Americans should sleep well at
night and have no concerns about this
particular rhetoric of these last few
days um can you look up with Harry
Truman to me I'm sorry I think I believe
German as I want to say to okay the bomb
if I don't know that that's terrible but
I'm pretty sure aidid anyway what else
you get chin all right don't talk to Jay
shabbat a free kill what is this
some girl named Chloe ailing she's a
British model um turns out that she
possibly well she's saying that she was
abducted through the Black Guard web
yeah and this is what it is to block des
dark web advertisement that's posted on
her belly right there okay and so some
journalist thinks that it could be fake
but apparently it's real and she is so
hot she so Hulk show she's spectacular
she was all up in the headlines on luck
yeah and I'll show his kidnapped by some
really rich guy or something so she was
lured by this foot like a modeling
photographer ad today we're going to the
pictures of her standards we were down
there and then someone abducted her
really and drugged her and she was
missing for I think a few days so some
people think it's fake some people think
in might she's she's lying about that or
hating the store it's looking to be real
now and this is the guy all the cheap
suspect and he said he was like he was
the Romanian mafia oh well threatened
him well you don't want them he doesn't
look like a very nice little I guess all
this more super pale white guy with
skewed I know so so did anyone touch her
don't you know according to her she got
away yeah
so there's look at her yeah she's absent
all that [ __ ] were talking about can you
collect him that would way let me see
what the headline says show it one more
time just said she got a they said oh
I'm still so she gets abducted they put
out an ad with her lying down with this
ad on her by the way that's a one-piece
in a very blurry image which is weird
okay to be sold well then how video show
to be sold on the black market dark web
I did not try and nobody borrow but
nobody not trying fun I was going to say
no I did not I did not offer up 100
pounds in that crazy and no one bought
her well I think the or did she know hey
I'm just the we're missing some Romanian
so meaning this is brainy so let's see
potential buyers 300 300 grand
let's check out this right here I mean
300 grand for that timepiece that is so
messed up
that sounds nice hey guys well that's 30
bucks you know it's more here a Russian
oligarch oh this is a different one so
uh apparently these guys in the dark web
tipped off a couple of British
newspapers but they didn't they didn't
say anything because the police said not
to do it so I guess the police
apprehended her they found out where she
was at oh that's okay so she likes cake
because it's tough was this girl to
escape the Russian mob or day I was
gonna say yeah it's not like yo they're
not like well it's not the movie whoops
ah you didn't tie that knot see yeah
she's running away
all right banana peel was in a way I
slipped Jesus man that's some scary [ __ ]
though for jeans [ __ ] delicious
cheese get a couple more items that just
your research firm as you listen yeah I
want to come up she did get away though
um but I don't know okay let's look at
more pictures sorry everybody trim with
the vice president
show me Brian shanks oh yeah she uh she
escaped huh we can't be mad at her sorry
um I'm just looking at her I shouldn't
mr. Graham I'm sure yeah go back uh oh
really I'm sick came back to that to me
Jen Jen - that that's her Instagram no
or 25,000 followers
those are real we can and no curves and
London boy were we full of [ __ ] Lee
where's she something else yeah she's
yeah she's nothing you know some melka
mighty Brennan
ah that's I would I would ask you to
else it's off that Brendan I'm going to
ask you to take it easy right now
because I would sniff friend hostiles
all friend and I'm gonna ask you to be
were being recorded and I'm gonna ask
you to really calm down here
she's improbably had someone's daughter
and she's just a good woman probably an
empowered woman it's why you guys know
that I believe in empowering women
Christ what's another traffic leave it
also if you're a little shut up about
this what's her name Qin mo wailing
business there's the holy a linking
Chloe a link there's a finger all talk
yeah you don't we hooked up about this
we're hiring a new intern aha boy thanks
for a terrifying experience I feared for
my life second book of Ezra statement
minute hour by hour I'm incredibly
grateful to the Italian and UK
authorities for all they have done
secured my safe relief I've just arrived
home after four weeks of being in Italy
had sometimes government Liberty to say
anything server until I've been
debriefed by the you faithfully that's
what she's wearing during her statement
it's pretty trippy right yeah she's a
beauty let's go ahead and get a better
dog though that's beagle ain't going to
stop any more of those abductors and get
those roots done as well while you're at
it
Finn's a dog Dyer roots that girl has I
think she wants you could shave her head
I'm no chair for her I wish you'd I want
her to know that they're actually make
up she figures of it you know yeah okay
Oh Jay Simpsons Bronco is gonna be up
for auction on that show Pawn Stars love
that I shall hunt from his ex agent have
you seen the new Broncos yes I'm getting
reloaded it may add a little amazing I
don't know I haven't seen him I love
that I love the Bronco the new ones come
now this comes out I think end of the
show how about Morocco so he's selling
it or his agent is selling his ex agent
so in other words he doesn't own it
anymore yeah
oh that's what happened as far as
ownership but it's it's not like illegal
he's alone mm not too green Bronco
firmly a great look come again that I'm
gonna getting that juice light to OJ
white I love it some black rims on it
cruise around Brentwood it screws them
right up the street why not why don't I
go relax man to have a car right I love
the Broncos truck oh I mean on truck I
had the old style it's really cool
looking really cool looking over looks
just like that in 2018
um that's concept but still it's gonna
be dope for it
let me see oj started to say how much
it's going to go for it says no less
than $500,000 flat allowance was famous
in it so okay does not get that money
once again no anybody he gets goes to
the gold it does it huh yeah like if
they found his pension he keeps his
pension they can't touch the pension but
like they found his kids had a bunch of
properties and flora like shitty
investment properties and then I quote
they sold them when they're under
different names they found was a kid's
name like would they get cash to buy
these now they're coming after that he
may I don't do this
they take Wow the Goldmans yeah they
want a thirty million dollar settlement
yeah I'm crazy Hilton 30 or 40 million
right good like paying that off I'm
starting Rogan this morning is we
talking about 100 or 1000 episode yeah I
go you should get OJ Simpson oh he's I
can be on in time but I'm calling from
prison I'd be hilarious he's getting
there he's doing Tom Segura and Joey
Diaz I'm doing a show right after a
freakin rat - commie story yeah I
haven't heard from Joe in a while he is
our Brogan Brogan Scott who's killing it
man every time out I mean I returned
about tours and ticket sales it's he's
won the biggest comics in the world I
thank Almighty you think you're doing
well in life and he talks on he's doing
well in life yeah and yeah I mean you
guys are all doing what what he's
talking about
it just levels to this game man as Meek
Mill said there's levels to this game
well emanates yeah there's a levels
levels that I got you know I'm over this
it's a commercial levels there it's rare
you can talk in not rare but there's
only a few people can understand like
with you know touring a podcast and
ticket sales now see Rogen's The
Godfather so when you I go you know
because not bragging because you're in
the same Lane right so I'll say hey this
I got this does this seem lighter dis
this and this and I got school I did
three shows I made this I went I lost
all energy my body was crash my Porsche
yeah
what yeah well he played to 6,000 people
in Dallas I mean it's only growing with
roving 6000 sold out three show that
6,000 that's I know what those numbers
are me too yeah good for him
let me go again there's levels to this
game yeah there are levels where it's
cool though dope it's so cool yeah how
do we get started on that he's always on
how do ya I'm gone I'm doing a show next
week when I'm doing while I'm doing a
show next week yes
1,000 what show are we on on this is
gonna be 281 281 anything special didn't
think but there's even more today those
don't document yeah once we do want that
book
for he's done we don't lie we're
probably like 600 500
I'm live at least 500 easy easy 500 we
started Brian's girl we do it right I
say week without fail we've been doing
that for words how many yeah so it has
the early ones in the very very early we
don't know where they live Fox used to
have them
fossum and then most a lot of hours in
transfer from fox they didn't let us
yeah there's only from 144 up on the on
firing the kid no the thing we're after
I'd say we're round at least 400 500
yeah fine father but you know we
surprise you something socially 400 300
sounds like a fun one too
should get drunk but learn on I looked
contact I like it me too he's brilliant
the pawnshop to heaven Hart Kevin yeah
Kevin hard be great man I only thought
the biggest comic in the world
wow we're a big cut podcast for sure but
you can't be still enough stuff out
there's my killer that's our hangout
talking yeah okay surfing do you think
if we had oj on when we get back less
calm i it would depend on how we handle
the interview
well mile seemed like him like uh a
stabbing mcgee you ever [ __ ] you were
thinking about killing [ __ ] well i mean
i think it'd be are you over that i'd be
interesting to talk about what his
little boys in jail was like sucks i
once all about jail what's next what's
next
then football chances and et in america
if you could if you could went back with
brain trauma been a big play knew your
whole kind of yo your plan to your
defense yeah i mean there are a lot of
great questions to ask them honestly I
still in the coach you know I mean you
know we could we are you still into
cocaine and murdering behind you could
go into would you like a new Bronco
right you can going back over if you
wanted but I mean it had a lot of salads
aren t you can't do that been done a
thousand times house you know we're
supposed to have Marshall Clark on the
show do you remember this yeah when I
was balls deep in OJ Simpson she had
written her people reached out to us
like we know Brendan loves OJ Simpson he
keeps talking about the theories of
people verso J or America for so Jen FX
and I love that anything ojm balls-deep
and that let the football stuff the
murder stuff yes not the cool stop the
murder stuff sure so I loved any
give me that stuff and Marcia Clark
people reached out like she would love
to come on fine kid however she will she
she will come on but can't talk anything
about though Jay Simpson well I'm out
[ __ ] me and talk about yeah if you had a
new book you wrote about he's probably
talked about it to death and I thought
look it's relevant now yeah it's very
relevant you can't talk like how you
lost the biggest case of all time where
you should worry drop the ball it's all
about dropping the ball yeah whoo yeah
how you were hooking up with the other
dude they were on the ball guy the car
with gas people drive by [ __ ] you and I
uh
yeah Brentwood way to have that one
that's thing you just eat it like you
just gonna come back to regular culture
they say he's gonna move easily in
Florida he's not giving me a little
bread
these kids are now that's right yeah
yeah that's where they get in trouble
because where I eat breakfast sometimes
RAF San Vicente the guy goes oh this is
and I did a bit on my show did Big O
this is OJ's this is a favorite place
he's ordered Eggs Benedict
like all right is he just gonna roll
back you know I'm saying just roll back
in there I don't know I don't know I'm
sure he'll find it I would be even out
you know and I'm listen I I'm I'm pretty
open-minded I like everybody I'd been a
little tense around OJ fees in that
[ __ ] I wouldn't be tense but I would oh
he's got out we know he murdered two of
them murder two people she I don't look
it that way you don't know flawed kids
no I don't think of it that way I think
of it as he flew into a rage in one
moment of his life killed two people and
that that would that doesn't make me
afraid of him it just I look at him and
I go man you know you live your life by
your own rules your whole life I don't
know I don't know much about you I know
what the documentaries say and what I
prefer pretty but or not into it which
aren't very flattering but for the very
sad guy yep it's fun it's like the
outsourced camp best friend
yep so so you know you got caught doing
this thing because you kind of always
felt like you were I think that's the
mark of a sociopath in the sense that
you are seeing this guy that's an
affront to me how dare you and now I'm
going to end
you yeah I'm gonna end him okay but
who's crying bar yes it is you know I
still didn't know how are you doing but
there's still crimes of passion that all
of us go like so all of us can see I'll
tell you a story my friends my father's
friend old friend uh this is [ __ ] 25
years ago murdered his wife was he's
from a traditional country you know very
kind of my conservative country wood
country um Pakistan and he was had his
PhD okay and he was uh married to an
American woman he found out she was
banging a dude spit of vinegar he
confront her on it and she said
something to the effect of yeah and I'm
gonna keep [ __ ] him so he flew into a
rage and took a lamp and bashed her in
the head Oh
and then but you know but he aged even
killing this but but he he flew into a
rage he loved her she was betraying him
and they always say betrayal when
somebody betrays you on that level it
throws everything that you know into
into flux like you know everything's
like I thought we were
what is cheat on me I've never like done
mistake this is this is this is he had a
child with this kid this woman the point
I'm making is that he lost his mind and
everybody no sympathy for him well
that's you but I'm just telling do be
yes I do I have anybody anyway J - no no
hold on just listen to me for a sec so
he lost his mind and he bashed her in
the head and he came down and he and he
was it was crazy he looked at this kid's
me because I killed your mother and he
passed it he fainted cops come he goes
away forever he goes away he just got
out of jail obviously he can't find work
he can't find anything I believe that
everybody at one point in their life can
be brought to that moment especially
when you're married as or especially
when you love somebody really bad and
they they betray you and you go could
you like for a moment I don't know maybe
you didn't sleep for two days maybe even
eat whatever it might be we know this
happens we know that good people can
lose their control of their impulsive
butcher I just happens all the time
happens all the time and so the bottom
line is in my opinion sometimes good
people
do very bad things and you know what it
takes they they shoot you they go crazy
they stab you with a knife this happened
it happens in relationships it happens
with lovers quarrels the first thing
they always do is like if somebody gets
like stabbed in the face of passion yeah
they go if he got sad in the face you
know I did I read think of heard a cop
talking about this I don't I don't I
don't think it's even true but a lot of
gay crime you know I get get spaced out
yeah it but also gay crimes is the worst
domestic Church because you you betrayed
me it's two men you betrayed me I'm
going to kill you you do that and then
you come out of it and you're like holy
[ __ ] and I think a lot it's almost like
fighting I actually believe if you if
you're if you're in a bar on a guy who
makes you mad enough to fight and try to
really hurt him and knock him out in a
way the times I've been in fights I
wanted to kill the guy I wasn't just
going to punch him I was I had deep
hatred and in that moment I was trying
to kill him can you relate to this to my
mother and my only normal person in the
room I'm telling you be
I've never wonder you're looked at
different sort but I tell my girl with
so Joe and I have a baby if I came home
tonight she won't listen I've got done
[ __ ] seven dudes there's nothing in
my body that would go through my mind to
kill her that does not exist in me any
fight I've ever been I've been way more
fight than you never what you gotta give
it out you've been you've also been in
what I'm saying is you've also been if
I'm a street fighter a streetlight live
in Moore Street I don't think you've
been in more than I've been I don't I've
been in I've been rich winning cross
hold on huh don't tell me that because
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about you've been more than like
anything I've been in as many fights as
you've been in home in in law read I
know you dude you don't fight I know you
don't tell me I murder
wheeler why do you don't know me you
don't know how I grew up as in as in
getting in fights in a bar you almost
saw me get into fights since you've
known me what are you talking about
don't say that you don't have the kind
of temper I do don't don't act like
you've been in more fights you're acting
like all I grew up rich first of all I
promise love is a slice with than you
Brian
what how many fights have been I
couldn't even count you I know you I
know how people you grew up in you I
know your personality you want fight
street fight knowledge
I was street fighting a street fight
with my brother the neighborhood we grew
up sure your interlayer that's the way
we grew up be yeah I I fought plenty in
high school and in college a you're some
bad I'm not your some bad I stay inside
all right I think I'm a badass why are
you doing that being insulting I'm not
being sorry so I've showed you Bella
hell no you're not you're you're being
condescending what your cell you're
going oh you rubber it you never thought
don't say that you don't know me so fast
because I have a bad temper you see how
I'm not upset today I know way through
exactly do I know where they kill her I
don't get the phone I'm making up I'm
making I started you make up a lot of
stories I make up a lot of stories I
make some out so I'm a liar yeah I'm a
lie oh shoot me a story I've made up a
real story first of all be careful now
how you speak B you're telling me yeah
who don't exaggerate or I do not lie I
bet I never ever lived
no I don't lie when it when it comes to
real stories like saying I'm a black
belt saying that I won the Nationals all
that is saying I was a wrestler
that's lies have I ever done that I have
character I don't lie I'm not saying
you'll have to yeah no you are don't say
no no Micah never said you've never had
to say but you're saying I lie what do
you mean by I lie you you've lied before
for sure give me an example uh late to
the studio all time missing shows I can
keep going on and I never lied about
that I like all we all love you hi
everyone I've never lied about missing
shows when I'm in shows I'm working uh
you've been late I go what are you doing
like uh you don't make up you move
you're gonna route when I when I go oh
there's a there's a break a main break
what do I do later I've never in my life
in my never lied to you a friend like
where I've done I've made up a story
inand not told you I was joking around
ever ever I what are you talking about
that I lie but baby this is wolf lied to
each other no but now you're not
Saint thérèse up in this never a hold on
we have not lied as an watch this is a
lie ready why are you late why are you
late oh because I had a doctor's
appointment and then you've never done
it never a little bit for real like
telling you that if I if I tell you I
late now you know what I wonder I'm
gonna hold on this is a lie
if um if there are people with and we
don't know and I call you up and I go
yeah oh there's a break there's a water
main break later on
I'm going to tell you I'm not lying I've
never lie fighting is a great example so
fighting the times I've been in fights
eh in DC or whatever the the let's call
it six times that I can remember in
college
alright terrified get in a fight because
somebody starts something stuff if I
were to tell you that I got in a fight
and I will kick this dude then I
question it to you I've never done that
in my life to a friend I've never
exaggerated I always talk about this
there's a difference realize and life
and here's a classic example we have we
know somebody who talked about being in
the towers right when when they came
down then what did I say I said here's
the way I lied one time I said and I was
talking about this is a fundamental
difference between a lie and a lie
this is very important we're going to
get back to the original point so that I
can talk about this one life is I used
to say well I used to have my coffee in
the in the lobby of the [ __ ] of the
towers every every morning you know in
other words what I was really trying to
do was I used to have my coffee I've
been there but my coffee out there was a
stand I'm not trying to relate so I
wanted people to understand that for me
and when the towers came down it was
really emotional still it's still lying
a lie but I thought but I was saying
that's that was the lie I would make not
only not to make myself look better but
I was trying to get people to kind of
relate to the fact that I had an
experience and it meant a lot to me
that's all or another example is that
sometimes you're here like an amazing
story and the way it's told is great and
it's a friend of yours and then
sometimes you don't know the people you
tell a story like you were there why
because it just it adds to the story it
doesn't then otherwise you want them to
think I he's just telling a third party
no no I want you to hear this great
story because it's a great story I don't
really care that I was there or not
remember I got start on this because you
said you've been in more fights to me
when you fight you feel like killing the
man yeah so let's get back to that what
I'm saying is that good people I believe
can do impulsive things sometime not
sometimes death well but sometimes I
think we can and in fact I think their
core colors agree I think their true
colors come out I think they've always
been that person
and when they face adversity they're at
that actual person you think is good
does the thing of passion I don't agree
that that is absolutely not hat with her
anyone that has a capability of
murdering someone if for whatever reason
they slept with someone else
well create well well so I don't know
and I think I think that there is there
is space for what you just said which is
a hundred percent true I think those on
the light green like when people get
drunk if you're a good drunk you're a
nice drunk like I get drunk and I'm just
nice I don't want to fight but if I get
it wrong because I like people trustful
different right so I'm a chemical
chemically yeah nobody but and also
messing with the biological makeup hold
that line hold that thought because I
believe anger does at some people and I
believe that sometimes your cortisol
levels and all those other levels in
your brain we don't know when you fly
into a rage and it's why Texas writ
recognizes what an act of passion a
crime of panic the past and I saw my
daughter in bed with this guy I saw my
wife in bed with it and I shot him it
was recognized by the courts as you were
it's called temporary insanity that's a
real defense and people get off for it
all the time so what I'm seeing done yes
you know we need to make we will usually
the temporary tannic actually you can go
to a hospital so what I'm saying is that
even the courts recognize and and their
psychological there's psychology behind
this recognize that sometimes someone
can be rendered temporarily insane okay
we know this does that make holding her
a mad person yes it does now I don't
think that ass now can we later to your
point I think that's the exception well
it is of course it's the exception but
to your I want to be killing the shirt
let them run to your point it's true and
I agree that sometimes when somebody
gets crazy right when somebody gets
crazy and they kill somebody and and
this is what I think with OJ Simpson I
believe that's the mark of a sociopath
because the sociopath will go you're
doing this to me and I'm going to kill
you and they say that one of the things
that sociopaths do is they like the
relationship is over when I say it's
over
the murders over when I say it's over
you know that nothing he was always a
bad guy or like that PhD guys just a bet
well we don't well I my parents know him
very well I don't know and I don't know
the man I mean III everyone has ID
everyone has demons right you're the OJ
Simpson thing the way the reason why I
think it's extra creepy is because I
didn't see the pictures but every one I
hated on for the pictures
there's no he's on another hell yeah
cutter oh no they it's true no he hit
her so hard
you know mr. kappa yes the first strike
yeah here are so hard it was like just
hanging on by yeah yeah forensic I mean
he they were both almost decapitated
from what I read so so but he was in
ganna see her before yeah but taking
that aside in my opinion like I think a
lot of times in life there is first of
all let me ask you this I mean he did
nine years and his life was basically
ruined lost everything okay that's I
think he should be put to death well
perhaps that's why we have a death
penalty and I think it's still in
California but he paid he's paid a
pretty big price not maybe not so wise -
yeah not the same no but he's paid so so
for me the idea of Punnett more
punishment for him I don't feel it I I
mean you know I didn't suffer at the
hands I don't have a family but still
getting a stipend of whatever is 300km
year at lea which is why I moved to
Florida cuz that goes not that far so in
Brentwood but still yeah I think you're
also very like forgiving of people - I
think that's part of your personal I be
a terrible cop because I am forgiving
you know I think that's just probably a
personnel well it is and I also do
believe I do think that again there is
something called temporary insanity and
good people do very bad things sometimes
it doesn't mean don't pay the price
right it doesn't it doesn't mean you
don't go to jail and I but I also things
you want years or so that I believe that
that you know when you get flying to a
rage you're [ __ ] your brain chemistry
probably can go crazy man it can change
you know also your concern related to is
your culture makes a difference honor
cultures like they see honor cultures
you know you can come from a culture
look at all these honor killings they
were having a problem with so a lot of
like like in Pakistan do a lot fewer and
it's not like your your your [ __ ]
daughter gets raped your daughter
commits adultery your daughter runs off
with another guy and the brother killed
her you know the father kills her this
happens all the time
this is this is a he's been brought up
in his culture to believe of a woman
betrays you it's the ultimate sin and he
flies into a rage because it's the
biggest enemy kills her okay now gotta
do time
I believe she go to jail I don't I don't
I don't excuse it however in that moment
I believe he will regret it later on I
bet you he weeps in his [ __ ] jail you
know I'm talking about the guy who
killed uh you know the right so so you
have this situation you have wife
beaters that do this [ __ ] how many
people who build their wives right so
and guess why they keep bringing the
wife keeps bringing them back baby I'm
sorry I'll never happen again he cries
he falls to the ground I'm going to help
and then he flies into a rage again and
[ __ ] b9y michelle has killed her
yeah yeah yeah you know you know click
on a Korean culture a lot of it's really
well known that the husband's in
boyfriends beat up their their wives and
girlfriends it happens a lot yes it does
that's my culture but I don't I couldn't
do that something it also depends on a
lot of also got out of that like drop so
energy Kevin got out of there but I also
I know that so on but you also take a
swift in the bitch's fate is it and by
the fit but by the way by the way which
in your your closet white Peter but
here's the thing we know that a lot of
culture is kind of because you grow up
with the idea there's a very strong
place for a woman a strong place for a
man and when that woman like humiliates
you betrays you and makes you in your
community and you're standing you know
kind of makes you look smaller that's
when the violence happens that's when I
leave
that's well but it but we know also a
lot of cultures [ __ ] he beats the [ __ ]
out of the woman he kills a woman cops
come and go what the [ __ ] well my
culture this is what we do I'm not
saying anything bad I'm the same bad
people good people do bad things
cultural reasons killing I just
chemistry reason I had a either aunt
who's murdered by her boyfriend and he
plead insanity and got four years yeah
so you have you have an emotional thing
around I really I don't that that was
just that's whatever I'm just saying yep
four years off insanity for years I
would be how crazy so bad yeah I was too
young especially me and her but yeah
that happens it happens because they can
cuz out if they can prove that guys can
prove
you know I mean I don't know hey I
wonder if head trauma had anything to do
with it - like sometimes well that's
what they're saying if the OJ cases now
brain trauma would be like a main yeah
you see all that stuff well this right
Robert supposed to [ __ ] I don't know
if 20 tournaments Ian McCall Sheila MMA
fighting not but I did watch it did you
watch a Brian no he was on AG fighting
with every Rowhani his interview he's
been on he's been here before - he did
not seem like that at all big brown
break yeah he's either up to me a few
times that's been busy and then he's
saying how like if you do it all again
he would never fight you saying how he's
having problems with his brain and what
else and regret how's it been here
agretti even started because he was
saying how he doing late - Chris Benoit
how you thought that uh people get weird
yeah but this is the thing I thought was
worth - line did some research on it
Chris Benoit you know that you know he
is now he was a WWE who went into a rage
murdered his family and kids then commit
suicide
mr. because of steroids and all the
stuff oh I remember this book but if you
talk to people and you look at like the
history of Chris Benoit beforehand that
happened he's like the greatest guy it
was like did he's the greatest dad the
greatest husband like an outgoing dude
so he was the brain trauma not so much
the steroid through one chunk of the
steroids there's more of the brain
trauma so he McCall was like I need I
need get help because I see that
happening before I'd ever hurt anyone
real and if you would never do so do
they would never do so - Robert Sapolsky
did Rogen's podcast he's it I believe in
evolutionary biologist but also a key
member what he does he and he studies
the brain and he said that joe said as
we learn more about the brain what do
you think we're going to do and Sapolsky
said i think a hundred years from now 50
years from now we're going to go my god
look at how we treated our criminals and
when all along they had something wrong
with their brain so they find that
poverty stress when you're growing up
trauma [ __ ] with the prefrontal cortex
where they don't won't let you develop
it it doesn't react the same way it can
be damaged and so it creates impulsive
behavior violence behavior would
associate inability to think ahead yeah
but what are you supposed to do just let
it like you know
oh right no I mean you're right you know
but people say that now but even back in
the day we're like God look what we used
to do criminal political ethics like
also like [ __ ] man yeah but but but
here's where people do you know who had
disabilities or retardation yeah we
thought they were possessed by demons
what the other but here's here's my cuz
they couldn't contribute aside to be a
rough life yeah but I read the time
raised a little bit of different
wrestling which goes back to what I'll
talk about punitive thing if you know
somebody is kind of not in control of
their brain for all the reasons we're
talking about head trauma poverty
growing up stress whatever it might be
chemical imbalance then when they do
something violent out of the blue like
this guy Chris Benoit or like God forbid
our boy you know here's a feeling don't
know United feels you know I don't mean
the warning I don't know your [ __ ] he
just said there's been cases where guys
Neela's get help because said down the
road 20 30 years down the road he isn't
having you those yeah he's just someone
ever happening but the question becomes
then what do we what what does punish a
sad story
this punishment look like right like
what do we do then like so I mean all of
us you have to have a you have to have a
prison that would help with brain health
yeah I'd have to lock him up yeah come
on run yeah please yeah you got to lock
him up
terima kasih you read that that thing
and it is a sad story man I honestly I
don't know what he was what was
happening to him but he didn't seem like
himself so I don't know what was going
on he was stuttering way more than he
normally does so I don't want to
fighting for a long time man but I mean
it was almost like I don't know where
this came out so I'm why did they really
have mom's on drugs or something what
why the dear shall have him on to he
could not promote meaning I forgot why
was not he was on but he was not going
through whatever is going through before
they booked this the interview
interesting so right when he got gone
the phone call with him or the Skype
call with him he just immediately said
i'ma call said like this is not a good
day
also some was some ham happened to him
like loot and I literally like moments
ago I could do how I saw talk to who and
you text me I get to [ __ ] in a bad the
article about the football players I
just get a hundred eleven I get the are
get the article service Brenda goes on
died
for real like an accident that
everyone's upgrade throw everybody right
that even with all stuff scary though
let's not talk to him he want help with
his podcast whatever storytime long
creepy what's the same thing man I go
through this with so many guys with
cowboy creepy everyone who asked me I go
have you been doing them nope there's no
consistency how would you keep up doing
them nope I can't help you man keep up
keep up I like doing a podcast like you
I did one and then I forgot took four
weeks off like well it did you don't let
me show ya you have nothing do you think
that as we learn more about the football
[ __ ] that football will will not be no
sir I'm it's the biggest moneymaker in
America yeah biggest draw it's it it's
it is what it is is more important if
especially kids who or grew up in a poor
economic stature
you'll ask them go hey man you can
become this go to college being like $39
thirty million dollars or stay here have
brain health live to your 90 but you'll
be working at the CVS and SVA you say
what do you want to do every single one
will say brother live that life also
that study like it is true that most of
their brain tissue was donated by family
members because they were the ones who
designed you and there are a lot of
football players I just talked to a
[ __ ] guy who play a famous guy and
he's 60
and he's [ __ ] who is it anyway I said to
my go do you have any of that blue [ __ ]
was it
and I go do you have any OCD because I
don't dude he got the first sign that
you can happen yeah here down you're 68
I'm probably a fact I promise you you're
not doing yeah but maybe it affects it
maybe affects people differently right
and maybe if I don't nobody attacks
everybody up in some way shape or form
yeah but yeah you mean differently not
always violent just others well like
something like Wilson for some people
and my [ __ ] would this part of the brain
got it were so right that they have real
short temper and then they flap the
hinges faster and they're really
impulsive and for another dude they get
really depressed yeah it's a real down
and out all time the other guy can't
remember things daily routines phone
numbers names another guy you know just
it just depends how to fake your brain
everyone's brains different the way it
was hit the punishment took yeah there's
so many this
so many things that go into it I would
also imagine to like some people haven't
like arm or injury at versed like they
tend to be better at kind of I don't
know seeing the shot is the brain no
like they were talking about this with a
doctor it doesn't matter the time about
the position you play the force like if
you know in football if you get hit and
you're you're both 300 pounds you have
the same force your brain does not give
a [ __ ] because you're even if you were a
helmet you're still getting rabble does
not matter yeah better if I'm Samoan if
you're white if he's black the brains
the brain I'll tell you what doesn't
help me in boxing is [ __ ] that
headgear you still get five chic and
it's worse for you
[ __ ] so maybe actually I don't I don't
know yeah but brain drums oh it's good
shipment all right let's move on to the
next turn event alright the next one I'm
the point one take from that as I've had
more street fights in Brendan oh yeah ah
Brendan actually mentioned this to me
who owned a mysterious flesh-eating sea
bug that lives in Australia the Seas of
Australia right okay Brisbane Australia
you don't know walk around legs wide
it'll beat you when to lotion yeah now
born it wait a minute hon are you
[ __ ] kidding me
here's the word at Neil's did you did
know their little tiny little mile I
post a video them devouring like a
fillet what it is really let me see that
[Music]
those are little [ __ ] tiny please
just around all the world listen man
I've been a civilian beetle I ain't
never been tore up like I've seen those
[ __ ] things I don't know man you know
what I don't look at my eyes skeptical
you got some bad guys cuz this your look
a little weird right yeah fake you know
it looks fake as [ __ ] to me it
definitely eyes and also in a hospital
bed they don't do that they clean your
feet off well what's he got rushed in I
guess he's way too calm
yeah National Geographic ooh they
message Augusta [ __ ] around not like
they do my eyes open up a little bit yes
National Geographic doesn't define I use
my eyes open a little sticking a piece
of meat in the water and you know you
know that you know piranhas don't do
that to you they don't eat you which I
was surprised by did you know that yeah
by people if you're if you jump in the
Amazon they're bunch of [ __ ] piranhas
that where are you [ __ ] now they will
not bite you hi Natalie
no that's the movies huh but they'll
[ __ ] a fish up but devour a [ __ ] fish
I mean I feel Astrid raffiq where
there's like one big-ass grouper fish
anyone's any like oh [ __ ]
yeah it's like West Side Story remember
how they take like a cow swimming or a
snake down make sure they don't do it
which in the Mafia they don't toss
people now in the River Monsters River
Monsters they're like now but I wonder
if you have like a big gash in your
stomach pronto is probably go they'll
eat dead so if you're dead in the water
del del del tear yeah Barracuda [ __ ]
your life yeah like I'll put a chicken
in there and it's [ __ ] dude who the
[ __ ] you lies about a good time you're
seeing Barracuda in real life I thought
swam with I caught him before oh [ __ ] me
sideways we got to bury tax return yeah
xbox went like the real ones there's
some panties on I got I got these small
ones like this - how about when Cowboys
in there was boy Mikey I'm no Mikey
forever his red head he's always calling
him the timeout lemon sharks I'm mm
focal in the shark anytime felonious
you've seen one start shopping like no
I'm [ __ ] other is a chin bringable in
detroit you've seen one search I've
written a murder so wherever that's the
bit we done fighting cute 3d times I get
it if it ain't a great white [ __ ] a
lemon all that yeah
but look at their Dodger I am lemons
okay so check this out so in Tahiti the
guy would take his take everybody out
and you'd be snorkeling you hold your
breath and he go come down here is that
that's a great white right there though
no that's a lemon yeah that's a lemon
yeah that's at the bottom and they're by
the way they're about 11 feet tall long
or not I don't know if they're like ten
seven eight let's see how long they are
there's always that don't bite oh well
the ones in like the Belgian shoe up
square him so so we go down there and
the guy the guy the guy the guy from
Tahiti he has us riding it so I held on
to the dorsal fin as its riding he
brings you over and you hold on to it
the guy goes the scientist at tetra
where he goes that is the three point
four meters I mean I've been our lemon
sharks dangerous so he goes first of all
that's dangerous there scientist goes
that's dangerous they could turn around
and bite you and it happens and second
of all it's so [ __ ] bad to do the
shark it's so disrespectful so they you
know went and found the guys they were
doing that for all of us tourists so I
got to actually ride it not that
threatening the only ten unprovoked
lemon shark bites maybe that's enough no
how about that but it's not but you do
have to watch your P's and Q's if you're
in them with the one I might not like
harmless because you know those ones I
think they called reef sharks where they
have all the teeth yes or harmless
they've never attacked a human in
slapping the stupid [ __ ] face they do
nothing like the ones you always see in
the creams and was a gum I got sharked
and the divers in there like oh he's a
rebel things up the [ __ ] of shark yeah
that's why I put in those tanks they
looked like Tarzan fight like Jane what
else she got this one uh sure you have
you heard the story that usher has like
three people accuse him of having herpes
and having sex with him two of them are
girls ones a guy David didn't put he put
her people him do this so actually they
tested the people and I think only one
of them has herpes so he definitely has
it so that's a game and have a break out
when he's [ __ ] these girls this girl
is accusing him of oh I don't know why I
don't mean to laugh talking about
blackapella that's that's one of his
accusers right there her name is Quan
Taoiseach Brendon don't why are you
laughing
her name's Qantas and Asia Sharpton all
right well and that's her lawyer
anywhere Hey yes I just not get any
worse rupture herpes ever girls like dad
[ __ ] all over the news he has herpes and
he's denying what no [ __ ] in other news
what what else uh what's the other thing
they didn't show that maybe he goes for
the girls was like low self-esteem you
know like you've used them as president
yeah she's a hardcore one I mean our
collaborators are to the hardcore one I
use this matter [ __ ] t-shirt and
that's terrible to try to add it up my
hell well I don't worry [ __ ] it's
already get down to one of my books I
see the good in everybody but at one one
let me see the one when I caught up gone
and are not gonna do not just pop out of
you did ya doing oh man you can't just
say she's a hardcore I like that man
oh one uh idea you've seen a one there's
well yeah that sounds some people like
it you know they're like a little
cushion
you talked why meet a little a lot of
cushion depending the sharpness says she
slept with us around her 19th birthday a
few years ago failed to tell her yet
herpes yeah well maybe at 19 I don't
know maybe the herpes like met her to
eat the world yes there's that and the
other ones a dude yeah two girls and one
guy
hold up scroll down what's a little
Serpas keep going which is I need money
oh yeah that was from before um and then
so that was one of the arguments for her
la came to they said just because she's
accusing him doesn't mean she's not poor
she's still poor and she was just saying
that wait I need some money feel like
that would hurt her
yeah oh yeah sure so the defense is like
do cheat off you means money
oh so she said this before so enjoy my
last couple of hours as a regular girl
and then she went after him you think so
oh well you know what when you do that I
smell [ __ ]
I mean all you're gonna smell dependent
oh man hey hey uh sure I get it man I
mean only New York on Manhattan night
yeah there ain't no time my life yeah
I've been that long you never you never
you never went hardcore one I've no
belong you never went hardcore ones you
never went HC HC oh yeah
you never went a co there went a
hardcore one that's all that's our goal
I've never I've actually contained never
been to a hardcore one I've been I've
been I've been and enjoyed a hardcore
for enjoyed it ah
good night sure April force yes a
grateful for I'm not worried about
staying the night a grateful for but
this hardcore one yeah this hardcore one
steadily stayed the night and got herpes
that's impressive
listen you know what she probably feels
great so let me just saw yeah claims I
said vaginal sex at least one one of the
two women and yet unprotected sex with a
man I never knew that did you know ever
know that he was you know I heard so
many celebrities just get my sex so they
get so many chicks they get so fed up
with it again this is like saying people
can murder people and it's all good I
don't get it
they had sleep with so many died pieces
like ah what's next is just [ __ ]
dudes you know it's like you said dime
pieces too and this girl is uniquely
different
well Ashly remember remember uh sure
started when he's fourteen with P Diddy
and he's in the heyday P Diddy so he's
saying he's at 14c and sex parties you
know it's basically like off three
hundred wouldn't it remember when that
the [ __ ] he's been putting it down for
a long time he's seen a lot of shits and
numbers don't make sense then you would
want to try different things like I
don't care how many people have been
with a hardcore one you never go
hardcore one one thing I've seen about
stars like that is that the year right
they well they tend to be busiest [ __ ]
and super disciplined and if they do get
weird you never see it like they're
really really just well yeah they're
with if it does happen it's happening
behind three closed doors for sure
I thought of story above the super super
super famous from a legit source who's a
friend of hers and she likes to get [ __ ]
on between her titties wait that you'd
think a hardcore WOM would like that
this is a stone-cold she likes to have
somebody to like poo well he's done with
the Cleveland steamer she likes that
yeah why should I have to be degraded or
something I guess I said you haven't
eyelets yeah some people are into that
yeah she's super super hot I knew ain't
a girl hot enough in this world for it
that [ __ ] girl you better be you better
be athletic I love because you're gonna
get up off of a heavy pile of [ __ ] I've
dropped some turds that roll yep like
your your you better be able to bench
press some weight girl it's gonna be hot
i I love my six-year-old more than
anything in the world
he takes a [ __ ] sometimes and I gotta
flush that thing it's I flush and run
it's available I don't want any I'm like
what the [ __ ] it's so horrific yeah [ __ ]
I have out here
they're cute you are when it comes out
of your body I'm running in the opposite
direction
the thing we do in college would you
would hack in the zones computer you'd
save their screen saver as scat babes
calm illness cat phases sure if you know
what lemon party organs do you have a
friend told me lemon party limp or is
that worrying about pee right
mmm can you go to chin no some parties
oh let's go just for connive damn it I
don't want that on my computer well no I
got to see it because because because I
know I knew a girl google google it I
know everything go to images I know a
girl Eastern children party org this
girl is turner I think it's so a guy
made her get would pay a fortune he
would have her hold her pee all night
long Friday he get in the bathtub and he
would she would pee on him and he would
drink it all CP is a little different I
feel yeah well you drink it he drink it
off dude I'm talking about dropping blog
son oh so let me have already mess no no
no no that letter by but boys not orange
not there there's a picture right there
you can enjoy that one click on that
click on that foot the other that see
what we got rid of the Coxon ball it's
old man Wow do you know man is it that
is just not my scene it ain't my party
bro i if
just can't nope not why did you tell me
about that we should save about people
screen savers in college do they walk in
like god damn it ah god damn it is right
that's lemon party doc some guys I'm a
grand alot of those guys so the
Grandpa's just chill he'll be glad on
the way
there's so much grandpa's swollen [ __ ]
man oh man huh that's tough to see in it
it is tough to feel good body
oh yeah say all right that's enough how
we yes sir a bunch of warm cheese on a
bed I don't know how that's done it yeah
but uh yeah I heard like a [ __ ] web
girl just loves [ __ ] really we went I
need to know who this is I will after
this yeah and you have a good resource
super in Liguria yeah she and she would
ask multiple dudes like and she's dating
celebrities like no I think about the
Queen now yeah my friend Johanna just
got more that's for a second yeah
think about the goddamn cleanup you guys
see I live like Dexter also who you tell
the whole place would have to be Plast
but how do you break the news like had
it like like Nick's worse and has a
great joke I'm sure he's done it special
by now but he would always go before the
internet trying to find somebody who is
kinky was really hard you had to kind of
be like hey you like getting [ __ ] on I
got know mean I'm just gonna run haha
yeah yeah yeah you can find that [ __ ] oh
now there's stuff I mean general
dedicated stat babe [ __ ] babe [ __ ] kids
so ever so some people so she likes dad
but how would you hey want to take a
[ __ ] on me cuz I know a very famous I
know somebody dated a very famous news
person and she goes right for the bunny
hole Nick oh yeah but that's a little
different you can freaky whatever I'm up
for whatever we talk about [ __ ] I called
the guy I wouldn't say so sir that's the
line you want over the line is that's
why that's a big problem no listen
that's the hard line sure is there's no
puss it was always my issue with an anal
too because you know you got you when
you pull your your piece out too
I'm gonna I'm going to steal from Jimmy
Schubert but it's a bit of a sewer
pickle yeah like I said hey there's a I
got a little is that a leaf a little
brown leaf or unsub's awesome
that's wait if you said you draw them
you guys draw the line at [ __ ] so you're
cool with piss no I'm definitely not but
I'm just saying I can understand piss
like all right read the guide rings
regen I'm open-minded if she was a stone
cold 10 if that model that English model
was like listen I'm down to whatever you
want but after in the shower you just
got a pissing oh yeah all right you have
to piss anyway that's all I have I first
of all I don't have to pay you or just
talk to your ear off into doing okay all
I do is piss on you yeah yeah that's
what close your eyes because I have a
heavy stream ever been hit with a super
soak in the face it's going to [ __ ] your
eyes up you big boy what big bladder I
hope you got a hose no this I'm [ __ ]
firehose but let me ask you this and you
can be honest and we're on air so it's
very weird but you ever have a girl kind
of a lude that she wanted to have you
pee in a never dump in her mouth you
have I have why I've had a woman to say
that that's something because we I came
here how it came up but she was there
was something about a girl who liked it
or a guy did that to her I know I
remember exactly what it was I'm exactly
what it was and my buddy told us he goes
and she drank my piss she likes me a
Dominator and we were both like I was
like what what the [ __ ] that nice girl
he goes yeah and I go alright well
you're a freak she's a free wait there's
a big difference between drinking piss
and your pissed on Shh drank well no
that's different so the girl that I was
with again I'm put up selves long time
ago by the way girls she was a freak and
she goes I can see that and I like you
would let me do that she goes yeah but
you know only you and I was like well
then you want to do it I was like I was
like I really appreciate hope that's
worth though because you can't pee with
a boner
so you set this limp dick you take your
limp dong out again I'm not really into
that I'm not interested in doing that to
you because I'm not gonna hang out of it
like get on your knees and get you know
but you know this happened
this is human being how do you have a
limp dick well she's on her knees like
hot as [ __ ] piss in their mouth I don't
get how well I didn't I don't get the
yeah because if I have a boner and
you're
knees I mean that thing is spraying I've
ideally yeah it's like yeah I'm seeing
like some four-year-old with a fiery
ghost yeah very hard to know they time
in the street stream I can't I have no
idea
it's like it breaks your heart you know
happens to me too everyone gets all over
the floor and the [ __ ] time yeah hey
what's going on I'm your four famous
street hey super sprayer it's like you
got to put it on I'm jet not on on spray
s are Kelly
alright that's this thing that's some
guys thing huh
it's a dominant thing they say Trump
likes get pissed on very well-known any
determine either German a germaphobe
without even it absolutely loves getting
dominated I don't know yeah you see bunk
at Trump probably runs a pretty tight
ship he looks like a tough yeah come on
cuz his daughter oh I'm sure she's
Milania Milania my dad she's like it's a
[ __ ] babe forty five-year-old oh this
you 45 yeah you don't get better looking
at $45 just personality that stuffed
koala bear but whatever I don't know
cold-hearted [ __ ] she some nails she 45
what doesn't happen she's killed it 47
she she's a classy woman what else she
gets in from mmm this one Rihanna posted
a picture on her Instagram and Chris
Brown commented it's just making a bunch
of a headlines obviously with no in
their past right and he's gonna get like
a restraining order against her Danny I
mean she I want to get his hand right
say you're always still a bit in a
bitter I still love their she's I'm sure
they feel really good here I mean Jesus
Kron 9 o-- 9 o-- 9 o-- 9 o-- [ __ ] on it
hey no you would I would and I would
fight you really ask me I'll be good
even though I've had a reason you I
would come in and she asked me I would
do it I would never do it on Rihanna
she's like listen be no I will fly to
real right now but when you get here in
order for us to hook up just [ __ ] on me
first she would never say that so I
would let you that's the only case I
would throw myself between her and the
[ __ ] you say dude I bet I'd say oh you
take a live turd for any sure would take
a live to her for her what would you oh
you got those googly eyes that's it good
night I blame them there's some women so
painfully beautiful
and so on and by the way can sing her
ass off like how talented you have to be
you look like that and you can say no
how big is a freak she is in the side no
they say she is just hungry and really
high girl like Jesus Christ I can't
believe he just said that I've never
heard that before one Chris Brown super
thirsty yeah she's really something else
she would be a high school in the world
huh yeah in many ways she's in my top
one I'll give that to you she's my heart
chord one like in my top lip yeah I mean
if they said you gotta swim in the world
you're like who's gonna be and they said
Rihanna like yeah I got it there's not a
whole lot argument there now she's so
delicious maybe you don't I don't do you
want to why for those things bit of us
with that might be what would you want
to marry Rihanna like you want her as a
mom right I don't know but she should I
don't know I mean I remember from way
back in the day on a MTV show where she
went on like a prom date with some kid
yes she was like the nicest most
innocent girl
not enough fun no well superstardom can
be it's kind of tough she she's killing
me doing little kitchen trying to see
here oh this one I don't know why this
just looks funny to me so this first
place runner and a 50-mile 50-mile
50-meter what is it
okay I have an opinion on this and I
wanted a walkers to burn so there's a
10k run okay so again I would go ahead
if I'm the same place when I'm finishing
first and Dragons that's exactly right
so the second place runner exactly right
and I actually have a problem with the
chair here's why ready yeah let's roll
down like this
he didn't win that race okay but he's
threw him down yeah but also it's unfair
to the guy behind him cuz the guy behind
him could have caught him wait so just
for the listeners a second place runner
there was a first place runner that was
losing his footing he's about to pass
out so the second place runner actually
held them up and then carried him over
the finish line chopping each other so
at the end yeah I would have I would
have finished first and I kind of came
behind me because that's the way life
works but yeah I agree with it it's a
good sport well I don't think a before
because he's not it because it's not a
real victory so what happened was you
didn't make it actually you collapsed
you might have not
even finish the race right each so your
buddy picks you up and runs you across
he beat you but he gives you that
charity thing and the dude right behind
I was running really fast he was
supposed to come in seconds look good
people doing good things I get that but
I don't know I don't think so I think
it's weird to me yeah what do you think
- yeah I don't know I don't know what's
on the line if it helps serious is it
are they friends are the family have no
idea it's marine oh you know what the
other Marines right or the Marine
Division Beach now autumn marathon
versus a marathon
oh wait you get $1,000 the cynosure
man's 5 pocket so he didn't get $1,000
yeah maybe it's it's 50 meter rate he
deserved to win no he didn't could
people do good things see you know
Cameron said hey bring up that article
by that uh the UCI echorec Rosen you
don't I'm out you saw he had a great out
so he's a he's the I mean he'll be a top
pick in the draft NFL Draft is cleric
from UCLA they asked him and he's also a
brilliant student his dad if I'd you see
I'm a neurosurgeon he's a beast so he
can I think his dad's a neurosurgeon and
he's a big-time pH you know doctor
something like that what was it again
uh yeah you see I you see life is go
away oh [ __ ]
damn I [ __ ] me right there uh Bruin said
football school don't go together I find
this interesting because it's all over
because he says you know and he's a good
student gets really good grades is
Kathleen you see a football we a
first-round draft pick most likely this
is a good year he's a beast
really smart kid I think the accountant
major a statistics major anyway he just
goes read this he goes look flip he's
taking so much football school don't go
together
they just don't try to do both it's like
trying to do two full-time jobs there
are guys who have no business being in
school and they're here because of this
path to the NFL there's no other way I
gun then there's the other side that
says raise the SAT eligibility
requirements ok raise the SAT
requirement at Alabama and see what kind
of team they have you lose athletes to
him the product of the field suffers but
he's taking heat but it's he sold that
on yeah he's telling the truth
but and he's also kid who gets good
grades doing bolt very well yeah and so
everyone's all
up in arms because he mentioned Alabama
but it's so goddamn true yeah in nas
let's be honest they don't get education
anyway I've heard you talk about it but
like if you there's some guys I know who
you know they were they weren't great
football players and really focus on
school and they got education but to be
like a super high level it's gonna be
tough to get that stage to man like
really focus on here get a good degree
in remember it just all-encompassing
right it's a full-time gig football is
100 steps will find mainly now in a
physical stop at your your watch on tape
right non-stop non-stop non-stop working
out training practices if you get it
right in the nose man people are upset
up in arms um but I think everyone who's
been through college football anyone
who's been around cycle now know why
everyone's upset why don't you pay the
players if they're if it's that
full-time of a job that's how I feel
you're not getting education you know
given give me a nest egg rejuvenate
would you play college do you want
college ball players in a program like
that they should as much money's amazing
yeah oh yeah they should
let's whole nother animal I think it's
funny ah yeah it's all over sport China
hope that I'll come on I mean gets kids
play football like you can but no one
comes here to get an education really is
you know
yeah they two full-time jobs yeah thank
you kids and but the staff like
departments know that because they give
you a schedule that's pro friendly of
you making sure you don't miss any
practices and make sure you get rest so
you're not giving the same schedules
other student right so I can say that
it's you getting the same education like
in exciting with teachers who are going
to be way more lenient if you miss test
and they know you're I can turn in on
time and so it's just you know I might
be on the same level playing my biggest
peer to win football and my biggest
problem is that the the you know they
say look you're here to get an education
you'll play football for us okay okay so
we know that most guys in a d1 program
actually don't go on to make it in the
NFL not only that even if they go to the
NFL they last how long right that was
Cruz to help you thank you three and a
half years so okay so let's see you guys
made a fortune off of them
they got no education they made you a
shitload of money now they are out of
college with no education
and no money I don't like ideal it's a
shitty deal sure you had a great time
playing football and you can say you
played at Alabama or Oklahoma but it's
still gotta be really quick like it's
funny when how much [ __ ] you get for
being real yeah when everyone's gonna
know so [ __ ] was switch lot of kids I
played with the Python that's right
Bailey true yeah and the kids who really
focus on education weren't that go
football players should be back yeah
okay why is it time ago I think we have
a phone call soon but I really make yeah
we got a very high-powered phone call it
Oh slam really quick technologies real
quick dropping Oz I thought was
interesting really quickly really cool
I'll be in Seattle so come see me this
weekend Seattle you bastards I'm at
parlor live and it's going to be a lot
of fun so that's this Thursday Friday
and Saturday
very quickly um so I just want to talk
about how when you frame something if
you're trying to make an argument frame
it in a way that people can understand
use language that that person respects
when do you know when they were doing
that when they wanted in Texas when they
wanted people to stop littering they
they were they were telling guys like
Bubba's in Texas I meant I got to talk
to him so that Keep America Beautiful
yeah and look like you were like - [ __ ]
you like Keep America Beautiful Texans
are like I'm Texan I'm a Texan I'm not
American I'm texting first they're like
keep messing so you know what they came
up with keep Texas grill and tread on me
oh nice and don't tread on me on so do
love me was the marine thing no it's too
close the military know it's a Texan
thing so so they said they once they
made that with it with a litter sign
like saying no litter with a thing
through that you know dropping litter
went way down because I didn't know your
demographic gotta know demographic you
haven't how to talk to him and when they
try to talk getting a little what can we
change to don't tread on me please they
were like no man that's not gonna work
same thing with Steven jobs I was
watching this marketing thing cuz I've
been trying to get into a little
marketing sometimes so bad at it and he
said when we talk about when we talk
about when milk when the milk industry
for 20 years start to get people to
drink milk and they kept talking about
why it's good for you why it's got
minerals and vitamins everything else
and milk consumption kept going down
kept going
then they came both got milk and got
milk everybody started drinking milk and
it was it wasn't even about milk is
actually about the absence of milk yeah
bill did but it was a value we were
selling a value Steven jobs say that
simple is I'm not talking about
computers not talking about bits I'm not
talking about speed not talking on price
but all the geniuses in the world he
goes Einstein all of Amelia Earhart who
had changed the human condition they
would have used a Mac everybody started
laughing but you know what they did they
think different and that's what he where
he came a little thing different that
was that was that was it he sold a value
so just know how to talk to somebody
when you wanted me to make a point
nice yeah all right boom once once the
long beach coach and the funny one that
I'm not at if you lessness right now
you'd be late anyway so I'm not going we
had to reschedule the Icehouse
I think of reschedule it for the end of
August or first week of September so I'm
not dice house tonight in Pasadena I'm
not sure whether it's still up but I am
in Long Beach on September 22nd that's
September right 22nd Long Beach Laugh
Factory those are almost sold out Long
Beach laugh factory September 22nd so on
my next show and we're rescheduling the
ice ice one and we'll have news for you
keep at K for Brian myself any show you
want to see get up get him this is the
fire kid you hardcore ones we're out